Casey wrote in saying hey when does it
make sense to lie to kids about things
easier to protect them or for other
reasons I don't know that there's any
rule Pat about when it makes sense to
lie to kids I mean you know we have a
picture of Santa here and there's this
idea that you want to let kids believe
in Santa until they figure out that
Santa's not real this is never something
I was involved in because being Jewish I
never believed in Santa I always
wondered what the hell is wrong with
those other six-year-olds obviously
Santa's not real it doesn't make any
sense but I think there's sort of a few
different reasons why someone might not
be totally honest with a kid number one
is if you believe is that your
understanding of something may be biased
or less than correct it wouldn't
necessarily lying to a kid but it would
be withholding information because you
don't want to pass on to them
information that might be wrong right so
a lot of times parents give these
examples of my kid is in the asking why
phase about everything why this why that
a lot of those questions you might not
know the answer to so you might not
respond you might actually just say I
don't know we're going to hold maybe
your limited information but I think the
more relevant issues for parents are is
this too early for my child to know
about and that's where stories of storks
is where kids come from appear that's
from stories that may be sanitized drug
usage or seeing public drunkenness and
coming up with some other explanation to
try to you know make it'd be less scared
or whatever I think usually protecting
kids is what parents think of as the
reason to withhold information if I were
a parent and I'm not and maybe my
feelings would be different if i
actually had kids i would try to be as
honest as as possible unless i thought
that it would actually be damaging and
there's this really funny story one of
my friends i won't say who because
they're kind of like like a progressive
media person but and maybe they haven't
told the story publicly but they told me
that when their kids asked where do kids
come from and i think at the time they
were like three and five they said out
of the vagina that was the explanation
and the kids looked stunned i mean there
was no question but he decided along
with his wife we're just going to be up
front unless it would
actually be damaging or scary we're just
going to tell the truth and that's it
and it became not a big deal yeah i
think this question really comes into
play when they're just not old enough to
know the actual explanation but i think
there's ways to get around the question
or to kind of put it off without
explicitly lying to them but it's tough
because kids want to get to the bottom
of things they may not accept your
question dodging so you I think that's
where the myth of the store kind of
comes from right but I don't think it's
ever right to do that I mean I guess
white lies playing around maybe you have
a surprise party plan and you want to
divert their attention elsewhere and
give them lies so that in the end
they'll they'll experience more joy from
it I think maybe those are justifiable
but in general I wouldn't support lying
to your kids is it fair to say that
sometimes you might make up a story if
you assess that the real story would
just be misunderstood yeah I mean of
course they're not going to have a grasp
of what the actual explanation is but I
think you can always you can always boil
down these big concepts into tiny things
that they can kind of understand and
even if it's a very base level
understanding of whatever the complex
topic is I think that's the better way
to go if a six-year-old ask who's Osama
bin Laden you know I got you say he's a
bad person right bad guy that killed a
lot of people you would say killed a lot
of people and at six years old they
understand the meaning of being bored
and being dead and killing him yeah I
mean I would certainly say what is Osama
bin Laden was a bad person who did bad
things to lots of people I don't know I
mean it's I think that this is why being
a parent is tough right i mean i don't
know because i'm not one but i can
already see how this would get it would
raise a lot of very difficult situation
I'm sure we're going to get plenty of
comments from parents in the audience
about the right way to do these things
and their answers will vary too we've
got a great bonus show coming up thanks
to everybody for being with us today a
very horrible day the day of Donald
Trump's inauguration of President of the
United States but hey we at least have
the bonus show to look forward to